[Music]
hello everyone
uh in the in one of the previous videos
i had mentioned
that once we have this equation
and once we have the
the value for p then we can find out
from this particular equation
although it involves this complicated
looking thing uh
the value of k such that this equation
is satisfied
because uh you note uh and i again
emphasize here
that the only thing which is not known
in this equation
once uh once a value of p is given to us
is the value of this
k and once we know the value of k we'll
have the knowledge
about this alpha because k is equal to
sine alpha by 2.
okay now because this is such a
complicated looking thing
but i had mentioned this also earlier
that uh
despite this its look it is a very
special kind of thing which
appears a number of times in different
fields uh so this
particular integral it is
it is referred to as the elliptical
integral of the first kind and
it is actually available as a built in
function
within symbolic python so we're going to
utilize that
uh to see how we can find out the value
of this
unknown k all right so on to jupiter
notebook now
okay so the first thing that we're going
to do is uh import
numpy
okay and
i'll also import uh
from the scientific python package so
this sci pi
scipy uh this is
uh it stands for scientific python and
uh within it
there is uh this special
package uh which contains on this
pre-built uh functions
so uh
so what i'll do is uh i'll import it in
a slightly different fashion because
this contains a huge number of uh
special built-in functions i don't need
all of them
i will just import uh only the one that
i need
and that is this elliptical integral
okay so from scipy's dot special import
ellipt k
that should do the job okay uh
all right so now that we have this what
we are again going to do
is uh
we are not going to separately specify a
value for this p
and then these different values of e i
and l
rather what we'll do is we'll specify
a value for this particular ratio p by p
euler
okay that should be sufficient so that
is basically equivalent to specifying a
value of p
what if we if if the values of e i and l
are also known to us
okay so we'll work in that fashion when
we have deal with
pure number of parameters so we set this
up
p by p e uh let's say we put this as 1.1
okay i mean we can play around with
different values but just for the sake
of
uh concretizing our process
we'll we'll just set it up and this is
just an arbitrary value okay we might as
well take this as 0.85 and
and test out various things 1.5 to
anything all right
now what we want to do is
see our job here okay our job here is
basically to find out
a root of this equation
where when i say root i basically mean
the
the unknown value of this k okay
so can i not think of this equation in a
slightly different way
uh that this minus this term
is equal to 0 so if i just if i just
write it like this
okay so whatever is present here that i
keep as it is
the p by p euler
just transposing this entire thing to
the left hand side
just this small change but what i am
going to say
is that this entire left hand side is
some function
okay it is some function of k
now my job basically reduces to finding
a value of k such that that function
value
is equal to zero now
uh let's see how we can actually
implement this idea
in uh in symbolic python okay so the
first thing that we are going to do
is define a function so we can give it
any arbitrary name
so we'll just call it elastico function
so
the only parameter which it will take as
input
is the value k so for different values
of k
it is going to give me different values
okay so i want to set this thing up
square root of
p by p euler
okay minus
2 by pi that will be written as 2 by
np dot uh
multiplied by uh this
entire thing okay this entire
integration but
i don't have to write out that entire
thing because that entire thing that
integral itself is captured by this
uh elliptical key okay
so
all right so uh that's all there is to
it actually
so uh let's just check if this thing is
set up all right
so what i'll do is just as a test i will
input some value of this k
now our immediate question is
if if we don't know the value of k what
value should we input
so a priori we do not know what this
value is
so but we do know that k is equal to
sine alpha by 2 as i have already
written down here
as you can see this k is equal to sine
alpha by 2.
now because of this particular form you
can be confident
that no matter what k is it should
always be lying between 0 and 1
okay it cannot be more appropriately
should be line between
-1 and 1 it cannot be anything beyond
that
okay so just as a test case okay just as
a test case to see if
if we are getting some value okay it's
always good to check that
let's just do this okay it is giving us
some value at least it is not
uh not anything like minus infinity or
or not a number
okay so you should always check these
kinds of things
okay uh now
uh suppose suppose we do give this as
some value greater than
1 let's see we give it 2 okay now you
see that this is not a number
because of course i mean k is defined in
such a fashion
and this elliptical integral is also
built up in such a
fashion that i mean this is a this is a
non-admissible value
okay so we will just we just keep it
like this
okay now all that is fine but how does
setting this
up help us in actually implementing
the process of finding out the unknown
value of k
okay these are just test values that i
was taking 0.2 0.5 whatever
okay but we have to find out the the
value
okay so our job basically reduces
to this that we will we are going to
input different different values
for for this at this place for this
elastic of fun
input parameter such that
this elastic of fun turns out to be zero
so this value that we are getting
this value should be as close to zero as
possible
okay so suppose we take this as
uh like this okay suppose we take this
as
sum minus value let's see what happens
there
you see uh it has become positive now
maybe i i decrease it like that it has
become
it is still positive if i if i go like
that
so you see this is a completely hidden
trial kind of method
i i don't know what is going to happen
so
just to get an idea okay just to get an
idea
of the behavior of this elastico
function
the kind of values that it takes uh
perhaps it's
not such a bad idea to to plot it out
okay we are going to go forward and
actually find the root of it
properly but before that uh it would be
uh it would be informative if we can
actually get some kind of a visual
depiction
of the values that it is taking so
towards that end
now what we are going to do is we are
going to
supply to it a range of values for this
k
okay so let's say we supply to it
this range of values
[Music]
let's say
like that so where zero is the lower
limit of this range
one is the upper limit of this range and
the 0.01
it stands for the increments within
this i could i could easily take 0.001
that is only going to increase the
number of values of this
a values variable okay so
i have that now what i would like to do
is
to investigate the various values
of this function corresponding to each
of these values
uh stored within the k values uh
variable
so if i do that you see i do get an
array of values okay so this entire
set of values that i obtained it
corresponds to each of these values of k
of the k values a variable uh
going from 0 to 1 with increments of
0.01
now uh i do have the data now all that i
have to do
is to plot it out okay so for that we
are going to use
uh matplotlib so let me do that a little
bit systematically uh
[Music]
i'll use this input cell itself so
i use this line such that all the plots
are generated within this jupyter
notebook itself and not
as a separate figure so that will keep
things nice and tight
but i do have to make some appropriate
inputs
so this is the standard way we import
the the plotting facility that is built
into matplotlib package
so this is matplotlib dot pi plot
something like python plot
uh that is usually uh within the python
community
imported as plt so i mean just like
we had done this kind of an import
earlier import numpy snp
which is a kind of the idiomatic
behavior of
people using python so also this is the
idiomatic behavior i mean you can use
anything else you might as well say
input matplotlib.pipe pi plot as tiger
okay or rabbit or elephant doesn't
matter okay
but this is just idiomatic behavior all
right
next what we are going to do uh so
uh we want to plot uh
on the x axis on our x axis this k
values
and on the y axis
this this this value okay
this elastic of function values now
uh what we are going to say is that
whatever the values we are getting of
this function
that will call as a residual so that is
basically a term from
uh from numerical methods so so any
difference from
zero uh that is like a residual so
uh again just a choice of a variable
uh name up but
uh we we actually have to store those
values properly okay uh
i mean we could do something like this
uh
let's try this type this thing works
sorry about that i missed one bracket
okay so it works uh i was going to show
it
you show it to you in a slightly
different fashion a slightly lengthier
fashion
but i mean this is just a easy
straightforward way of showing you
uh so it works uh of course
please note that that when you actually
go into a real project work
please do not leave your plots in this
kind of a bare bones fashion it is
extremely extremely unprofessional
i sincerely urge you to please present
your plots and your figures
in a nice professional way where you
take care
of the size of your fonts
here and here and very importantly that
you never
ever forget to write the the label in
the x-axis the label in the y-axis
okay so uh in instead of pontificating
let me just
uh let me just try to do that myself
okay so on the x axis i have the k
and on the y axis i have the residual
i'll just write that
like that but even this is uh not quite
professional
although uh it is is just satisfying the
bare bones necessity
okay you should do better than that okay
in a in a real project work
okay so so we have the values of this
residual like this and this k here like
this
please note that these values uh
of the elastic of function that we are
obtaining this is uh
corresponding to our choice of
p by p e okay this p
euler this ratio this particular ratio
okay that is very very important to note
all right now
you see what we are trying to get at
here
is that okay fine we have obtained these
values
okay and wherever this particular curve
it intersects the uh
the x-axis okay so our x-axis would be
some is a horizontal straight line
passing through this
uh so let me see if i can just you know
plot that out
okay so plot k values
are just for visual so ease of uh visual
understanding
i'll just plot a series of zeros whose
length will be equal to the length of
the k values variable
let's see if that works okay that's it
so you see this is a horizontal straight
line passing through the zero
and now wherever this uh this plot
it it passes through this uh this
this horizontal axis it is somewhere
just from visual
observation we can see that uh our
visual inspection we can see that
somewhere here okay a little bit
this 0.2
uh
sorry about that little break uh
okay so
so as i was saying uh our job basically
boils down to actually finding out this
particular
root okay so now all this is just a
just a rough way of estimating the value
of the correct value of
k we we understand that it should be
somewhere close to the 0.2 value
but we really have to find out the exact
value so how can we do that
so what we'll use is uh we'll
will utilize the root finding capability
uh
within python uh and for that we'll
again have to import something from
this uh type so from sci-fi
so this time we are going to use the
optimize package
which has the root finding capability
built into it
okay so from sci-fi dot optimize import
root
and then
we have to supply to it the name of the
function
and then we'll also have to supply to it
uh
a a value which is
uh which is an initial guess okay so
if you are if you're a little bit
familiar with numerical methods
uh you will remember that uh sometimes
for these initial methods we do
uh for for these numerical methods we
have to provide
an initial guess so let's let's provide
initial cases 0.3 maybe
let's see what happens okay
so you see uh it does give us uh
something now this something is the
actual
solution now you see
here that uh i mean it provides the
solution in
a slightly uh slightly strange fashion
but
the key thing to note here is this thing
the success
true okay the solution has converged
it's true
and the real answer that we are looking
for that is present within this
x okay so what we are going to do
is we are going to
write like this or we can write it here
itself
solution is equal to root of this
okay now of course it doesn't write
anything but we can just display the
we can display the solution again and
display that thing
and then we can extract from this
solution structure which is presented in
this
fashion uh this x
okay and from that x we can go
a little bit deeper and then extract out
the actual value
this zero and that will be the the
answer
to our k so that will be our k
[Music]
all right so our case solution
is this and let's just check for once
if that is indeed true
so what we are doing is we have gone the
other way around
and now inputted the case solution
answer that we have just found
back into our elastic of fun and let's
see what it gives us
you see this is nicely zero that's what
we wanted
okay so if we use this value of k
solution
corresponding to the choice of p by p e
that we have started out with
we do get our answer okay so what we
were saying earlier
what we were saying earlier that given a
value of p or equivalently p by p euler
our job is to find out the value of k
such that this equation is satisfied
that job is done now okay
all right next once we have the value of
this k
what we are going to do is to try to
find out
the uh the deflection w okay
so let's go back to our notes and take a
look there
of what we have done so uh
we had covered the steps and then we had
arrived at this particular expression
for w
okay so this was present in the in just
the previous video
and uh now you see
uh our job is i mean almost
uh done in the sense that we can just
code it up okay but there is a little
bit of a problem in the sense that
this ratio is still not in the form p by
p
e that we would very much like okay so
let's let's uh
let's set it up like that and you also
know that this uh
this sine squared theta by 2 that that
can be again
rewritten in terms of the file so
let me just go to this put one next
the new page and
i'll copy this thing out
go to the next page
and just redo whatever i need
it may be a little bit of an adjustment
over here just to make it look a little
bit better
okay i think i'm happy there
all right so
you see i introduced this pi square e i
i also introduce this l squared
so that uh
what i'll be adjusting here is with this
pi square
this p and this l square okay
this term here will be k square
minus now you please note that earlier i
had used
this sine theta by 2 is equal to
uh k sine phi
all right so this thing is going to be k
square
sine squared phi
all right so what i'm
basically getting here is that uh
this is going to be twice l by
pi so this l is coming from this l
this l square so you please note that
this is under the square root
and this pi squared is coming out as
this pi
and what i'll be left inside is this
p euler so whatever was present in the
numerator that is p a
pi square e i by l square that was my p
euler
and i just have this p left and this
term
is simply k square minus k square
sine square i think i should be writing
that as
the other phi not as this phi
okay now
you please note that uh although we have
supplied in our code
in jupiter notebook this ratio p by p
euler which is the
just the inverse of this but we have not
yet provided the value of this
l okay but not to worry what we can do
is
we can normalize this uh this deflection
which is
a length value uh by this
l okay so we normalize or
non-dimensionalize this w
by l so what we say is w
tilde or w bar may be w bar
is equal to w by l
is equal to 2 by pi
[Music]
square root of one divided by
p by p euler so i'm trying to write it
in a fashion
uh which will help me to
directly code it up in jupyter notebook
okay so this is what i'm going to write
there
okay this w bar basically i'm trying to
plot not w
but w bar all right let's see if we can
do that
so the thing that i have to input here
you please note
that before i go to the jupyter notebook
that
when this theta it goes from
it basically goes from alpha to minus
alpha
or you can say that it goes from minus
alpha to alpha
either way so when it goes like that uh
then this phi it goes from
so let me write that down that
as theta uh
goes from
minus alpha 2 plus alpha
i should write that as the proper phi of
course
the phi goes
from minus pi by 2
to pi by 2. and you can just check it
here okay so
theta is equal to i think i did this
earlier but
anyway i'll just do it quickly once more
so this is minus
sine of minus alpha by 2 is minus sine
alpha by 2
and this k itself is sine alpha by 2.
so this is uh
this is sine phi equal to minus 1
so phi is equal to minus 5 by 2
and when theta is equal to alpha
i have sine alpha by 2
is equal to sine alpha by 2
we put a dividing mark over between
these two
so sine phi
so sine phi is equal to 1 which implies
pi is equal to pi by 2 which is exactly
what i have written here so when you
have theta
going from minus alpha to plus alpha i
have phi going from minus pi
by 2 to pi by 2. so this basically
supplies to me
the range of values over which i should
vary
my phi such that i obtain my value of
w bar rest of the things are already
known to me i have just now found out
the value of this
a and this p by p euler i have already
taken
so i know basically everything i just
need to plot it out
all right let's do that
okay so phi i'll put the range here
uh minus pi by 2
to pi by 2 and let's say
i want to divide this entire range which
is
basically pi so as we go from minus 5 by
2 to pi by 2
the entire range is is pi
and that i will divide into 200
divisions
okay so uh let's say
we set up our n as 200 i'm setting it
out like this so that if we wish we can
later change n to maybe 500 or 1000
whatever
we want if we want finer finer
refinements in our increments
all right now
now correspondingly i would also want uh
i also want the
the values of w uh
what i can do here uh
is uh let me just take a look
so i want this particular form right
uh so let me see if i can write that
down directly this w bar expression
so this should be 2 by pi square root of
let's try that w bar is equal to
2 divided by pi times
square root of 1 divided by p by
p pi e
and then i have this part square root of
k square minus this
times square root of
k square minus k square
times um
[Music]
sine i
but that should also come with a square
let's just check that
right k squared minus k square sine
square phi
i mean i could have converted that into
a cos uh that would have been easier but
all right i just keep it like this
okay that has been far easier to write
actually um i would have just ended up
with k
cos phi uh anyway i've already written
it
so let's see if we can if you can obtain
this
uh so again just like before
let's try this
[Music]
um w bar
let's see what it gives us
um i think somewhere i may have missed
okay that's it i'm getting my solution
for w
now uh the first uh
emotion that you have when you have such
a plot
is happiness but then uh a certain
uh almost a little bit of a negative
feeling may creep up
in the sense that uh does this really
mean that
this this kind of a deflection if this
is indeed the w
and please note that it's not even the
double is the normalized w
so this is w divided by l uh is does
this
this deflection curve does this really
mean that the that the beam is
deflecting in such
such a uh like a fantastic fashion
but no okay so please be careful in
noting the units here
okay or the values here so you
look at the range here this is minus 1.5
to 1.5
and this is going from 0 to 0.2
this is a really really small value so
in order to avoid any such
illusion regarding the the the way in
which it has
and this deflection is shaping up so you
please
uh you can try to set uh the act the
aspect ratio of our
of the axis as equal okay
now you see it's much better okay so
so this is uh this is a little bit more
physically intuitive
of course uh once we have this code
ready
uh so whatever we wanted to achieve we
have achieved
but please note that we are working
under this
rather arbitrary choice p by p e equal
to 1.1
now it is our hope that
if we if we increase this maybe you
should be getting
uh larger values of the deflections so
let's let's check that
so once you have the code ready uh you
should
go into a scientific uh or a
scientifically curious pursuit
to to to get further insights into the
actual
physics of the problem okay uh let's see
of course you should be careful in
noting that uh it should be getting
answers okay
i mean
okay you see here the value of k
even if even even before we go into the
actual root finding
you can see that it has considerably
increased
uh the value of this k solution so
maybe it it's a good idea to
to help symbolic python a little bit to
give it a
value closer to what we can actually
visually inspect from here
so it is again success is true so
we do have a solution in our hand and
let's just check
if it is indeed so uh so
earlier we had obtained a value of 0.0
that was
that made us perfectly happy but you see
here this also should make us perfectly
happy
in the numerical method since uh because
this this is basically just
2 times 10 to the power minus 16 which
for all intents and purposes uh is zero
okay so i think we are good here and
and before before i press shift enter in
this in this cell
which plots out the deflection you
please note that uh
it's more or less uh in that 0.25
range let's see if that increases or
decreases
okay it will be it will be interesting
to see
so we don't see much of a change here
sorry i have made a mistake i believe
ah right because
the k is okay what i should have done
earlier also
is to take a value of this case solution
properly
okay so here this k should not be a k
it should be a k solution okay it should
be a k
solution the value of k if you look at
the code
if you look at the code it was uh
it was not even present so
you should be absolutely right in
suspecting like what that something has
gone wrong here that why it was
accepting it was not even showing an
error
that k solution uh that that k was given
and it was not even defined why was it
giving
uh an answer even so the the issue is
that just before i had started the video
i was just trying out a few things and
from that i had not
i had not restarted the kernel and that
is why that k value
that that that value of k had was
already present
uh in the environment okay so
let's let's do this now
once more you see that it has it has
slightly increased
so what we can do is we can and go back
and change this to 1.1
and run the entire code again
it is taking a little bit of time you
see
it has gone back to the previous kind of
solution
and we have this thing here okay so this
is this is actually less than 0.25
and if i just remove this thing this
equal it will be
it'll be easier for us to actually look
at the value it see it's quite
it's even less than 0.15 okay now i go
back
and change it to 1.5 and then read on
the entire thing
let's see what it does now
you see it has increased considerably
okay previously for
a value of p by p equal to 1.1 it was
giving a value
of the highest value of the deflection
less than 0.15
and please note that this is the
normalized value i think i should
apply the labels here
so plot x label
so this is a 5
and the y label here
is
[Music]
w bar
[Music]
oh sorry that's a spelling mistake there
okay
so this bar is barely showing up let me
just just try to write rewrite that
okay that's better
so this w bar value here is
uh is close to 0.3 for a value of p by
p euler of 1.5 and
just as a last check
[Music]
there are a number of things you can
test out here i'll just read on the code
here
it only takes a few seconds
you see it has increased okay
now uh what i'll do is
i'll i'll reduce this value let's see
what happens then
0.5 and this time i'll not run all the
all the cells together
uh rather than run just run them one by
one so
um
now you see this is rather curious okay
that
is rather interesting you see when when
we plot this out
uh in the in the admissible range of k
from 0 to 1 then
it is not cutting this horizontal axis
passing through 0
which means that for the value
of p by p e euler
has 0.5 that is what we have chosen here
that's a let's say that's a relatively
small value
compared to the values that we were
choosing earlier
we do not end up with any
solution of k this is basically what is
telling us
so what this what this what the
interpretation of this result is
that for a value of p by p euler
equal to 0.5 basically
our beam does not buckle okay that is
the prediction of this
theory so it's really pointless to
proceed after this
for this value of p by p e equal to 0.5
okay
next suppose we increase the value to
let's say 0.9
what happens then
you see it is this almost touching this
but not quite it did
we still don't have a solution so p by p
euler equal to 0.7
uh 0.9 doesn't also give us anything
what about 0.95 it's it's quite fun to
actually do this thing
uh see it's quite close but not no it's
still not touching it
you're not crossing it uh if we increase
it
to one okay add the value of the p
euler
okay so we may have a solution here and
let's see
what happens if we if we actually
actually try to run this
okay so it just does say that it is
success true
but you just note the value of the case
solution it is
generating okay so it is practically
zero
okay so for k solution equal to zero
that's what we are getting
and uh
of course i mean if we run this then
also we are going to get this
k solution that's fine but uh
if we run this you see
the deflection that we're getting is
of the order of 10 to the power minus 17
okay so that is basically
zero okay so if you had to actually
uncomment this line and rerun this this
will look like a straight line
that's it okay so even for a value
of p euler equal to one the more exact
theory that we have found out
involving this theta s coordinate system
that is telling us that
that is there is barely any buckling
here okay but if you just increase it a
little bit
more okay as we were doing earlier
uh for a value of 1.1 or maybe even 1.05
okay so now if we run it
you see there is a nice crossing
of this line of this horizontal line and
we do get a solution
we do get a solution which is not which
is a non-negligible
value okay
and this time we should be getting some
some
some visibly some visible buckling here
okay so there is a lot to explore once
you have the code ready
so i believe uh this thing will
encourage you to
to explore uh such uh such situations on
your own
maybe you can change the boundary
conditions a little bit and
test out and rewrite the code and see
what happens
okay so on that note i'll end this video
thank you very much